a former Michigan State quarterback
Connor cook back on the program where
are you today Connor i'm currently at my
house in hinckley I'll ain't hanging out
at home what's in your bedroom on the
walls actually there's a picture of
Michigan State the stadium spartan
stadium right above my my badness back i
think in two thousand it's like a photo
so you pan around panorama photo back in
two thousand eight i think when they
were playing illinois what would be
embarrassing for us to know that's in
your bedroom right now uh you know what
nothing really i mean if you were to go
back and like middle school like 73 it's
great i'm sure there was something
embarrassing but right now it's pretty
pretty basic just cause you know I've
been at school basically for the last
four and a half years so the only thing
I could think of right now it's on the
wall it's pretty bare it's just the
painter anna panorama photo of michigan
state's field and then there's like a
spartan clock i have on the other wall
did you have any posters growing up
besides it yeah i did I was uh I was a
big snowboarders growing up and I wanted
like obviously sportswear important I
played basketball football baseball but
I was really in the snowboarding and I
want to be like a pro snowboarder to
like whatever sport i was in at that
time I want to be a professional at it
so when I was playing baseball I want to
be a pro baseball player when I was
playing football I still want to be a
pro football player and then when it
when winter came around I was
snowboarding I want to be a pro
snowboarder and I had all these trail
maps I went to so me and my dad we've
been the Keystone we've been to
Breckenridge even the veil and Aspen so
like I got those trail maps and like
laminated them and put those on my wall
and so I had like multiple trail map so
those are my posters growing up ok buddy
the places I've done if you could spend
a day with Tom Brady or day with Shaun
White Tom Brady oh so yeah back then I
mean battle back then if you ask me like
in 7th or 8th grade I probably I for
sure what it said shaun white right now
I'm a little bit more into football than
I am snowboarding well I hope you are
where you gonna be tomorrow I'm gonna be
home here
in hinckley Ohio just hanging out as
members coming over a couple buddies
it's going to keep when I trying to have
like a huge part or anything just some
just some people for will get together
and hang out and just hope for the best
do you expect to hear your name tomorrow
you know what I'm honestly going into
this draft you know expecting the
unexpected you know obviously doing in
the first round that's great you know
that would be a huge blessing and you
know I think I deserved to hear my name
called but um you know anything can
happen so um you know if I don't get my
name called I'm not going to be that
upset because I'm thinking I'm going to
go in the second round you know so I'm
going into a more thing I'm going in the
second round and if I hear my name
called on for on Thursday tomorrow night
then then that's awesome so really
anything can happen and no it's a crazy
process everyone keeps telling me man
these next couple days are going to go
by so slow so um you know just just like
i said before expecting the unexpected
the last two months fun or frustrating
you know i would say fun you know that
times you'll you do get a little
frustrated and annoyed you know at
certain things but I think overall
looking at it I mean it's a
once-in-a-lifetime deal you do the
combine you do the pro that you do all
the team visits I date of those so I was
pretty busy for about two and a half
three weeks you know you're going to
look back at some day and be like man
y'know that was a good time that was a
fun time leading up to the draft you
know everyone always talks about the
path to the draft and it's not easy
that's for sure but I would say more fun
than stressful and more fun than you
know annoying whatever it is but I think
I've had a pretty good attitude going
along with it and I've had a good you
know support team with my aging and my
parents and my family I'm durable
process we had a zekiel Elliott on
yesterday and I said who who loves you
who's in love with you and he said the
Chicago Bears are in the Miami Dolphins
do you have a team right now that you
feel like I think they like me a whole
lot or maybe a team that loves you you
know I think as a right now and I think
the niners like me
you know I've heard the Denver Broncos
like me and the Dallas Cowboys um you
know and I felt like every place I
visited that people like me but who
loves you to know i don't know that i
know the answer to that you know I I
don't know if I really felt loved
anywhere I've gone you know obviously
the coaching staff at San Francisco was
super cool i like those guys a lot I
thought the coaching staff when i
visited miami for the Miami Dolphins you
know Coach gates and coach kristensen
and coach Hart agree those guys you know
we're super super nice down-to-earth
just just good people you know the
Denver Broncos and I visit there pretty
much everything and Buffalo Bills I mean
their whole coaching staff super super
nice so um yeah I don't know if anyone
was like well was there coaching staff
that wasn't nice like everybody was nice
to you Conor was there a coaching staff
otherwise yeah no no I think everyone
know there wasn't like oh that was oh I
was gonna say was there one that was
like all damn it Connor cooks here who
was it taken out to dinner I guess I
will yeah that's the thing like that's
what's so hard like I don't know what to
expect I mean all these teams were like
cool and they were nice I mean it's
that's what's so crazy then all sudden
drafty rolls around and then it seemed
that you think oh you know they seem
like they lightning the best and also
mental pic yeah so that's why I'm just
going in expecting you expected I don't
know what's going to happen I honestly
people are have been asking me you know
not stop over here and go what team you
fingers is going to pick it where you
end up I literally have no idea okay
because then there's times to wear a
team that has not even talk to you
before and then all sudden boom they
take you so when you order on the menu
are you are you cognizant of they might
be watching to see what i order do i
order the most expensive thing on the
menu like you get it in your head of
they could be analyzing everything here
uh at times and i usually just ordered
the same thing every time i went out to
dinner with them yes Caesar salad you
state you know yet some vegetables along
with that so they know you like to eat
healthy and you know usually a steak
isn't super expensive and the places we
went weren't all that super expensive
they're they're good restaurants or a
nice restaurants but nothing that was
just totally crazy and then
how many beer wouldn't i order yeah 0o
you know okay okay does that might be a
red mountain are you shouldn't do that
of water to drink of the water and
little bit but um but yeah it's been
good i mean there's time see where you
do think to help maybe that maybe they
are watching you know every single move
but i've just done myself to throughout
this whole process and you know you
never want to change who you are that's
for sure okay do you think you satisfied
the question about not being named
captain your senior year that that that
seemed to just hang there why didn't
Connor cook why wasn't he named captain
for the for the Spartans you got the
question do you think you came up with
the right answer that satisfied teams
yes I think so I thing i did and going
on eight visits getting asked the same
question everywhere I went they had a
pretty solid answer for that but um you
know it's kind of kind of crazy for how
you know I kind of took off and how
people just ran with it um you know talk
about my game you know nitpick my game
say oh he doesn't throw the comeback
that well oh you mean he's on used to
work on his deep ball accuracy stuff
like that but it's just when you get
people talking about your character and
who you are and its people that have
never even met you you know haven't even
sat down and talked with you for five
minutes you know going on just saying
stuff like that and really you look at
things that are saying its like the
complete opposite so I think it's kind
of funny how it all kind of took off and
how you blow out of proportion of God
but you looking for this whole process
to be over you know being on a team
having team select me you know being
able to know where I'm going to go you
know just give me the playbook and learn
it and get to work and let me start
grinding Connor joining us on behalf of
Old Spice if you'd like to give the plug
since you're now a professional getting
paid to do these things yep so uh Old
Spice able to link up with them and get
some nice stuff you know I go i've been
using old spice all the way back you
know thing all the way back in the sixth
grade when i first heard using deodorant
so i've i've had some familiarity with
that with that brand and i used a little
bit of the body wash growing up in high
school and kind of got away from it but
now they got the whole deal they got the
deodorant obviously they got the body
wash again
the shampoo and conditioner now which is
all-in-one so you're like saving money
on you have to go out and buy you know a
separate conditioner and shampoo I mean
it's all in one afraid the fragrance is
awesome smells great you know they got
new hair gel as well you know they got
the pomade they got the gel they got the
cream the stuff to make your hair look
really really good like yours and then
itís to pick up the new deodorant so the
the the main fragrance that they've been
putting out as a swagger which I've been
using this past year I go back last I'd
using get her in the sixth grade up
until this year i always used after
hours so that I kind of graduated from
that and moved on to swagger which i
think is a lot better now but I mean
they got the whole kit and caboodle
one-stop shop that's what it's called so
I mean you got the like I said the
conditioner and shampoo the body wash
the hair gel the the deodorant and it uh
it couldn't smell any better look at
that you sounded like Peyton Manning
they're selling old spice old spice calm
for more information have fun tomorrow
and hopefully you hear your name if not
then Friday you'll hear for sure but
thanks for joining us Connor hey thanks
for Adam Ant always a pleasure alright
that's gonna cook Michigan State
quarterback the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience